I'm kind of the opposite and people I
think think that I am
um I think they just want me to insult
them because so many things that I've
done in Deadpool this is the whole run
of me insulting Ryan Reynolds all
through Silicon Valley I was always
insulting so I think people think of the
yell stuff out though and it happened
more it's happened less now that I've
become I guess more famous or people are
just like don't that that's not okay to
wrap used to happen all the time every
single show
but now yeah if people yell they kind of
want to be involved and I'm very quick
because I started out as an improviser
I'm quick to go into the crowd to talk
to people and that's what's so weird
about this special dear Jonah because I
did this I have these specials that are
coming out that are all completely
improvised stand up so it's where the
audience gives suggestions for names of
jokes and that's my set list and then I
they I would have a projector and they
throw up the name it could be whatever
like Karl Marx parts or something like
that and the first time I see it is the
first time the audience sees it and then
I turn around and do a joke completely
improvised right off that and I finish
they threw up the next joke and so I
started as an improviser that's really
fun for me are you committing yourself
to putting this out like regardless of
how it goes yeah totally well and what
you do is you get rid of the stuff that
absolutely didn't work but yeah you have
to have some things that show you
fumbling and not doing well right but
for the most part the audience is just
amazed that you can even and do it in
general right present something so when
it's really funny then they're just like
what the [ __ ] just I'm amazed and um but
I do a lot of crowd work I speak with
the audience I'll I talk about my day I
have a lot of stuff online that's kind
of I show up in Winnipeg and just talk
about Winnipeg and what happened that
morning and it's just it's all
improvised the audience loves it so I
love to throw that stuff up but in dear
Jonah the strangest thing happened which
is so when you film a special you know
this when you film a special you have to
do two different shows usually there's
two different shows at theater or
something and then you pick the best one
and then use that as the foundation and
you patch up any little issues with the
other show so I figured out a way to
shoot these specials so that they're
television quality but I can shoot four
shows or five shows so I did four shows
in Nashville
and the first show went pretty well
we're like ah we don't have it at all
it's just me warming up and then the
second show you know Late Show Friday
sometimes they're like oh this is gonna
be a disaster people are so drunk and
also it is the worst and people are so
drunk uh in Nashville so I said
if I get out there and they're just a
mess I'm just gonna riff and we'll have
that on and the director said no no
honestly we don't really have it at all
so just do the exact special again and
hopefully we get a couple of good things
then we'll we'll Bank those I said we'll
see what happens
so I go out and I start performing and
it's the best audience it's such an
amazing audience I'm like how is this
possible that SEC somehow it felt like
these people had drank perfectly
they were absolutely all professional
drunks which is I guess Nashville it's
either a bachelorette party or just Pro
drunkards and I'm performing and I'm
like this is it this is special I mean
this this is the audience that I want
for the special and then this [ __ ]
guy in the front row starts just talking
and I was like ah why is this guy
heckling and it was weird you know how
many you're really drunk but you have
audience members that are drunk and
they're not trying to be mean or
anything they're just drunk in a way
that they forget there's other people
and it's just Stevo and them in their
living room and they're listening and so
they'll just talk to you and so he
started doing that he's like Ah that's
true yeah yeah oh yeah no that makes
sense how good that was good and I was
just like God damn it so I ignored him
for a little while because he was
[ __ ] up the special I mean he's
talking and especially
he was frontistro he was the most front
he was practically on the [ __ ] stage
really his he could have leaned his chin
down and he was is on the stage right
there so it's like all right what am I
going to do I've got to just talk to him
I'm gonna try and shut him down
and then I'm gonna move on you know and
then get back into what I want to do
which is film this special that I it was
going to be called the pandemic special
to show people what I was doing during
the pandemic right and it's it's
particularly difficult when you're doing
crowd work on camera to pull in anything
from another show because you've got
different audience members and for the
rest of the show if you call back to
that person you can't you can only use
that thing in that show so yeah you're
totally [ __ ] kind of so I said all
right I'm just going to talk to him get
done and move on
and so he's right in the front row so
he's wearing cargo pants and I go oh
you're wearing cargo pants what kind of
cargo you got what do you what do you
call it what's your Freight you know and
he starts to talk about cargo pants and
he's like I I I just like cargo pants
even though I don't
keep anything in them and so it's
immediately clear he's developmentally
challenged this guy is like you know
yeah he is not he's not a drunk Heckler
let me put it that way that is not
what's happening right and so there's
this moment where he finishes that thing
and you can feel the audience is like
what is TJ gonna do because the real
moment am I gonna lots of comedians
would just be like
I like cargo pants you could absolutely
have done that but that's not me and so
I just took a beat and I just turned the
audience and I'm like I want all of you
to know that I am not going to make fun
of him at all and they just erupt
everyone's laughing and clapping and
stuff because then everyone can just
relax and this this kid can relax too
and then throughout the show he starts
to come back in I like ask him some
question I do this at one point he just
I say so it's quiet and he's like
hilarious it's hilarious and I was like
it is hilarious and as The Show Goes On
he becomes more and more incorporated
into it until by the end of the show by
the other special he's kind of the star
of it and so I changed the name of it
from the pandemic special to Dear Jonah
because it sort of ended up being a love
letter to this guy who I'm sure and he's
the hugest fan of mine he just loves me
and he says that a couple times in the
show and the the closer of the show I
involve him and there's this guy who's a
total idiot [ __ ] this guy named
Trevor which is the perfect name for
this dude when you see the special and
you know I mean it's you gotta see it
but it's unlike anything else because no
one's ever had something like this
happen and even if they did they would
cut it out probably right they would
move away from it right which is
hilarious because now there's this whole
ableist thing and they're saying you
can't say spaz and all those sorts of
things and so a lot of people said to me
well you shouldn't probably cut that I
was like why would I cut that out that's
able That's not including I want to
include him in the conversation he was
the show he ended up being the best part
of the show and so that was the craziest
experience for me of a Heckler right
because I thought I was being heckled
and turns out being something completely
different and so throughout the whole 45
minute special you're just like you kind
of halfway through sir be like where's
Jonah I want to see Jonah do some stuff
again and then he does it's amazing yeah
if only I had hecklers like that I've
just got absolute [ __ ] oh I've got
those two and then you just gotta tear
them apart and I get some really
entitled white women yelling [ __ ] and
getting upset at me that's actually in
the special also but um yeah usually you
gotta shut them down and make fun of
them my technique always is to like
contextualize their behavior like
recontextualize so somebody will be like
wasn't that funny or something like that
oh my God you would be a great dad you
know what I mean somebody comes back
with their look Dad look what I drew
today not that good I gotta give you a
beer and get the [ __ ] out of the way of
the television so you kind of you know
you get it right that angle sort of but
this was a great example of how I do
crowd work but it also kind of shows
that I'm a good guy I think you know
there's some people are like oh he seems
like an [ __ ] and it's really you can
tell on the special that like all I want
is for this to go well for this kid yeah
forever and it's it ends up being so
great he showed up at 4 P.M he's the
first person in line
biggest fan and that's why he was
sitting this close to the stage because
he got there and I I thought he was with
his family and I later found out that
they were just people at his table who
would befriend him that his family had
dropped him off and that he had seen me
before
found this out afterwards and he uh was
in the back of the room and he liked it
so much that he decided in his mind I
like him so much I'm gonna sit as close
as possible as I can and they also the
the uh venue zany is the comedy club
they said
um that he asked can I get closer to the
stage how actually physically close can
I get to the stage so it's amazing it's
like such a bizarre thing that happened
and that happen any single night of my
life as a performer any of the hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of shows I do
and it just happened to be on the night
that I had a six camera shoot and was
filming the audience so we caught
everything from him
it's pretty it's pretty special pretty
awesome yeah people say they tear up at
the end of it some people are like it's
almost because it's like emotional at
the end you're like it's great yeah you
gotta check it out I think that clip was
awesome but not as awesome as my new
book a hard kick in the nuts what I've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions my first books Five star rated
on Amazon and I have no doubt this one
will be too so get the autograph copy
right now at stevo.com
yeah dude